t 4
あみなさんこんにちはエー
この日料は月さらまわし
dvd 疎水沿いを part 1ということで
あっ初めてねー
こうあずきまーすよ実際にやってみるとが最初にどのようにさあもしようかなっていう
のを見れてビデオになってるんですね
か付けます第五復旧
外れ思想があずき版すぐさましたとか
どのようにして小豆を回せばいいかまたそうする
あずきナースの素晴らしさを徹底的に
みんながセを入れるやついいところから始め教えていこうと思います宜しくお願いし
ます
ています今日ねこう
初めてを預けましょう
実際にやってみようと思っておりますえっ
5をそして素敵てくれたんだけどなーっ
お願いします今日初めて弾ませてるんだよねはい
ボス衣装じゃなくなるでしょはいどうぞ天板とかしたかっただけでしょ
そうですよいますよいいかだけどまぁそうなのねうーんそういう生徒も多いからね
ぱぎがあってとても楽しいシェ授業中とかああ
運用2玉をよって言ってるから明日んがぜひ今日は僕たちと一緒に預けませんなって
いきましょう
じゃあ皆さん預けますよしていくという家でまず必要なのは
なお箸ですね犯すです見えますかねちょっとしていくですまあこれが8位でペン回しで
いうペンになってくるんですけど実際ちょっというかここに小豆が小鶴あるんですけど
まずはね基本的な寿命とからしていきましょうはい
長谷を使わない基本的な運動可能性できますがもう
なぜここに一つ目の仲間月があるんですけど
f まずあずきと触れ合うことからはじめましょう南江堂キャンパー聖書あずきって
抵抗あると思うんですよ
行けて練り軽度で受けたんですねまずはコア関とコミュニケーションをしてみましょう
が泣けるとか月のことをひたすらこう
触ってみるとうーんさていいんじゃない
これ
んですようーんぞ小豆はね
まず皆さんに覚えてほしい技な
大東チクリ渡すということですよ
作り私ですね
まずまずがなくだけじゃないですかただぞ昔からね
台湾から座ってくだされ台湾カーヤ軍でこれで世界1からを取っ的な地球言い渡し
付ける様だせん
まあコザに2つの
コーサラなると
族にゅっちからなってなくそういう父は関係ない開発
乳じゃなくてくびれ放送ですねっていう大紀行きれいなアーチを描いて隣の
この
三流の今32の方へ移すと子どもたちは実際やってみなさい
vtr どうぞ
ぐうっ dare
まあ今の日であるご覧いただければその今みたいに幸を掴んでねー
rei てもブーブー籐スクリーンへ
ん
バッハ